are you now between Megan and malignant
are you now only doing Bunker's horror
I like to think
more that I'm doing horror films that
are not afraid to sort of push the
boundaries but that still play Within
you know that sort of commercial genre
space but really you know it's just me
growing up loving all kinds of horror
movies and uh you know I've I've done my
time in the haunted house genre I've
done my time in sort of like the ghostly
sort of space so I you know as a
filmmaker I'm always trying to expand
and just kind of push my Horizon and I
think that's the great thing about the
horror genre is it really lets you kind
of free you up to try things and do
things and that's the most important
thing for me is like just trying to stay
original and you know and even if I'm
inspired by things that I love I want to
find an interesting new way to do them
okay but I still want to say Bonkers
horror
I'm trying to stay away from that term
I've been using that thrown around quite
uh a lot
um I was just talking to Gerard and he
said that you're already talking about a
Megan sequel
Gerard what does he know uh I I don't
like to talk about sequels
um uh so early on because the movie
isn't out yet I'm just only because I'm
superstitious okay um but what I will
say to that is like any of them in my
movies you know like whether it's you
know the conjuring universe or saw or
malignant or you know or Megan here is
you know we like to think of a bigger
world right it's about for me it's about
sort of creating the world and kind of
knowing who the characters are where
where the story could potentially sort
of go and uh and then sort of like
building this bigger world and then
going into that and going okay I'm
telling this particular story but I know
all the stuff that's going on so if
we're fortunate enough to have sequels
then uh we have an idea of where we want
to go any thoughts about maybe uh Megan
versus Annabelle
two separate Studios
you never know um
now can you tell me a little bit about
your partnership with uh Blum House and
is there any
um IP that you're really interested in
tackling that Jason Blum has well
um it's obviously very early on and
there's um you know not a lot I can
really speak to at this moment but to
answer that question
um hell yes of course yes and and
obviously not just at Blum House you
know with universal as well so that
that's about to the extent I would say
Melanie here
um what about uh Conjuring 4 can you
talk about that at all yeah we um we're
working on it right now um you know we
we actually you know what we with The
Conjuring films uh you know we we we're
very precious about and so uh so we kind
of want to just take our time to make
sure we get it right and to make sure
like the emotion of the Warren stories
that we want to tell and moving into and
potentially wrapping up you know we just
want to make sure that it's the right
thing the right story that we're telling
with wrapping up does that mean that
this is going to be the final Conjuring
movie
we never know you never know we'll see
um can you talk a little bit about this
is her part puppet part CGI part human
part A Little Bit of Everything well
what I would say to that is you know is
we again to Gerard's credit he really
kind of wants it Megan to feel
as real as possible and uh and that was
where I sort of worked with Gerard can I
go we we wanted to feel as possible but
also at the same time we still need to
remember that she's a doll and so we
don't want to go too far that direction
as well and you know the dough aspect
generally is what makes her kind of
makes the killer doll genre you know or
or the creepy Dojo on a creepy because
uh because it's clearly in in an
inanimate object it's a play thing it's
a doll but the fact that this play thing
could have a life of its own is what
makes it makes it scary and so I think
you know I would say for the first time
that the idea of that uncanny valley
actually really helps a movie like Megan
it actually makes her makes her feel
creepy to be sort of like in between
real and not quite real can you talk a
little bit about casting um Allison and
Williams yeah I mean you know I I love
Ellison and I mean we all do Alison has
a history at Blum House and uh and so
you know so you know from the get-go we
we thought of her for this role
um just because you know we think
Allison's very she's perfect to play
someone who uh is very career driven
very smart you know she needs to do what
she needs to do to kind of create you
know to be this programmer that she is
but at the same time she also has this
sort of softer side and uh and we felt
like it could be a great sort of
contrast to see her pulling the softer
side out of herself to be you know the
parental guidance to Katie uh and I
think um May uh um Allison is perfect
for that how did you go about finding
Katie I mean with young kids it seems
like it's very hard to find the acting
chaps yeah I mean Violet is incredible
in this
um you know just you know we we do our
research
and I'm so glad we we found her because
she she does you know because so much of
the movie is built around her emotion
with the doll so you know so if she
didn't really work then then the movie
wouldn't work either